thanks for joining us for the news here
at noon everyone we begin with breaking
news right now
out of the east valley ccsd police
investigating an officer-involved
shooting it happened near sand hill and
twain
kristen drummond they're live on scene
with the very latest hi kristen
alex the shooting happened at around
nine this morning outside harris
elementary school
as you can see here behind me this
remains a very active investigation with
a couple law enforcement agencies out
here
you can see cherokee avenue right now is
taped off no cars are able to go down
the street
as officers investigate what happened
the clark county school district
confirms that this does involve a ccsd
police officer
a source tells me it happened during a
traffic stop
the district's motorcycle unit was doing
enforcement around the school when an
officer pulled a car
over the driver requested the officer
supervisor
who came over to talk with the driver
and then at one point the car suddenly
drove away
and the gun was fired now the district
reports
no injuries and police are still looking
for the driver
right now we are waiting for an update
from ccsd
or metro police about what is going on
with the investigation if they've
located that car
of course we will give you the latest
details online
as well as on social media as well as
eight news now
dot com reporting live in the southeast
valley kristen drummond 8 news now all
right